STEVE FRANCIA:
Welcome to my session,
"Enterprise-Ready Modern
Applications with Go--
The Rise of Digital Chaos."
For years, one of the
most talked-about topics
has been digital transformation.
It seems like everyone's
feeling the need
to modernize their legacy
enterprise applications.
As technology has specialized,
it has grown exponentially
in complexity.
Two decades ago there might
have been a dozen choices
that needed to be made, with
typically two or three options.
Today the amount of choices
is simply staggering.
Nobody can possibly
begin to understand
all that is required.
3/4 of CIOs say managing
performance is now
impossible due to
the IT complexity.
Security risks have seen a
similar exponential expansion.
It seems like every day we hear
about another major breach.
The historical approach
to enterprise architecture
doesn't work in the digital age.
If we don't dramatically
change our approach,
and soon, it will be too late.
Today I'm here to share
with you what the path is.
We need to modernize our
enterprise applications,
and a lot of folks
have this wrong.
They have part of the
picture, but haven't
grasped that true
modernization requires
simplifying our approach,
not simply containerizing it.
Who am I?
I've spent the last decade and
a half leading industry-changing
organizations, focused
on bringing simplicity
to the chaos.
As senior vice
president at MongoDB,
I led the development of the
first non-relational database
to enter mainstream
use in 45 years.
As chief operator at
Docker, I led the effort
to simplify containers.
As a side project
I created Hugo,
the most secure and highest
performance web engine.
Today I'm one of the leads
of the Go Team, where
we are building a modern,
simple Cloud-native programming
language.
Since you might not
be familiar with Go,
I'll first provide a short
overview of what Go is.
Then I'll share with you
what a modern enterprise
application requires.
Lastly, I'll share with
you how Go and Google
Cloud will help you with
migration to modern enterprise.
Along the way I'll share
quotes from enterprises,
and how Go helped them.
Go is a modern programming
language designed by Google
for Google's problems
of building and serving
server-side software at scale.
Google uses Go extensively
for a wide range of things,
from our indexing platform
that powers Google
Search to the infrastructure
that Google Cloud is built on.
Launched a decade ago, Go
has seen explosive growth.
Today, Go is a top 10
language, with broad adoption
among the world's
leading enterprises.
Go follows Einstein's Maxim--
be as simple as
possible, but no simpler.
As Go is designed for
maximum simplicity,
it is very easy to
learn and to work with.
Go drives the balance between
productivity and performance,
sharing the friendliness of
dynamic languages like Python
and the productivity of compiled
languages like C and Java.
As a modern language,
Go was designed
from the very beginning with
security and safety in mind.
Over the past 10 years, Go has
developed a large and mature
ecosystem.
Go is loved by both developers
and employers alike,
ranked as the
number one language
across many industry surveys.
Go is widely loved by
developers because it
makes building modern
software simple and secure.
But what does it take to build
modern enterprise applications?
First of all, they
must minimize risk.
They must be fully modern.
Adding modern components onto
or alongside legacy systems
introduces significantly
higher risk and complexity.
Instead of simplifying things,
they multiply the complexity.
You now need to worry about
many systems, languages,
and integration points.
They must be safe.
Modern applications
have to be built
in a way that ensures safety.
According to researchers
at Microsoft,
70% of the security bugs that
the company fixes each year
relate to memory safety.
Google found a similar 70%
of serious bugs in Chrome
are memory management
and safety bugs.
Legacy programming
languages were not
designed with safety in
mind, because at the time
there was no such
thing as a cyberattack
and bits were at a premium.
Our environment today is vastly
different from the one legacy
languages were designed for.
Modern languages massively
de-risk applications.
They must be secure.
One of the largest
risks systems face
is in the form of lacking
security, which results
in leaks and attack vectors.
In the constant
battle for security,
applications need to
utilize the latest
encryption and protocols.
They need to run in
minimal environments
with maximum isolation and
minimal external dependencies.
They need to not depend
on legacy libraries
and environments.
Modern enterprise applications
must adapt to business needs.
One way they do
this is by utilizing
service-oriented APIs.
Approaching applications with
a communication-first focus
ensures that the application
has the proper separation,
scalability, and flexibility
to adapt to new business
requirements.
This approach also isolates each
feature for greater flexibility
and security.
They must be architected to
be modular and composable.
Tech debt can be a
technologist's worst enemy.
This hidden tax slows
down all development.
Traditional inheritance-based
architectures
create code that is
very tightly coupled,
and hard to adapt
to new requirements
and very hard to maintain.
Which brings us to
our next point--
they must be easily
maintainable.
Teams and priorities
are constantly changing.
We need code that is easy
to understand and pick up
by a constant influx
of new engineers.
We want applications that
require minimal maintenance
without constant
runtime upgrades.
Our final theme is that
modern enterprise apps
must sustain growth.
They must be scalable
and efficient.
Data and usage has been
expanding exponentially
for the past five decades.
With the end of Moore's
Law and increased pressure
on computing costs, modern
enterprise applications
need rapid deployment
and the ability
to scale up and down with ease,
using resources efficiently
and keeping operating and
management costs down.
They must have a
Cloud-native architecture.
Modern enterprise
applications must
take advantage of innovations
in Cloud computing.
With the Cloud-native
architecture,
they must be designed with
automation, monitoring,
and repair from the beginning,
favoring managed services.
They must incorporate
event-driven components,
also known as serverless.
Event-driven features
must be properly utilized
to bring cost savings,
adaptability, and efficiency
to modern enterprise
applications.
This requires software
that loads instantly
with minimal
resource consumption
and minimal dependencies.
We're now going to go
through these requirements
and highlight the ways
that Go and Google Cloud
Platform will help you build
modern enterprise applications.
Go and GCP help
you minimize risk.
Go is a truly modern language,
requiring a completely clean
implementation, keeping
your application decoupled
from legacy libraries.
While there is
risk in a rewrite,
it pales in comparison
to the larger risk
of sticking with legacy
systems, or worse,
maintaining both a legacy
and a modern system.
Go's high learnability,
productivity, and simplicity
minimize the rewrite
risk, and often pay
dividends in massively
reducing both operating
costs and technical
debt, further
minimizing business risk.
Zviad, a Senior Principal
Engineer at Dropbox,
said, "People become very
productive in Go very fast.
Our infrastructure
is built in Go today,
and all the new things
we build in Go."
Legacy software
languages were designed
for a different era where safety
wasn't prioritized, or worse,
often compromised
for performance.
This trade-off made sense
in a pre-network era,
but has created massive
risk in today's environment.
Modern languages
like Go are designed
for today's environment,
where safety is critical.
Go is memory safe,
type safe, and utilizes
low-latency garbage collection.
These features alone avoid
over 70% of critical bugs
resulting from unsafe
legacy languages.
Bala, a Senior Director of
Engineering at PayPal, wrote,
"In our tightly managed
environments where we run Go
code, we have seen a CPU
reduction of around 10% versus
C++, with cleaner and
more maintainable code."
Go has been designed to create
the most secure applications,
minimizing risk as
much as possible.
Go applications compile
down to a single binary
without any local dependencies.
It's not uncommon to
see an application built
using only the standard
library, or only a couple
well-vetted Go dependencies.
Go's dependency management
uses an industry-leading,
tamper-evident transparency
log, with built
in tooling that ensures
that your dependencies are
exactly what you expect.
Go has native
encryption, which is
used to power much
of the internet,
including key components
of Google and Cloudflare.
Adopting Go means that
the next Heartbleed, which
impacted virtually every
application written
in any other language, won't
impact your application.
Go even supports
distroless containers,
where there are zero local
dependencies to worry about.
GCP, CI/CD, and Artifact
Manager have direct access
to Go's Vulnerability
Database and can provide you
instant warnings about
security threats.
Finally, Go and GCP will help
you adapt to business needs.
Service-oriented APIs
provide enhanced agility,
scalability, and reliability,
allowing your business
to adapt to market and
strategy changes quickly.
Go is the only language
explicitly designed
to build service-oriented APIs.
Go has native support
in the standard library
for all you need to build
performant and secure APIs,
including a
high-performance web server.
This is Go's most
common use case,
with over 70% of Go developers
using Go for building APIs.
Matt, a Principal Software
Engineer at Monzo,
shared, "Go is a perfect
language for creating
microservice architectures.
The concurrency features,
and the language in general,
has allowed the easy creation
of small and simple network
services at Monzo."
A unique feature of Go is
that its application structure
directly mirrors
the architecture
of service-oriented systems.
Services are designed
independently
in a share-nothing architecture
communicating across networks.
Go applications are composed
of share-nothing modules
communicating across channels,
a native feature of Go.
This means that both your
service and your application
composed of many
services are using
the same architectural pattern.
The benefits of
agility, independence,
and easy maintenance
are twice as impactful
for Go-based services,
maximizing your ability
to adapt to business needs.
There's an additional
cognitive benefit
for developers of using a
single architectural pattern
at every level of your system.
John Graham-Cumming,
the CTO at Cloudflare,
shared about Go, "I came
for the easy concurrency,
I stayed for the
easy composition."
Kubernetes creator, Joe Beda,
tweeted, "Kubernetes success
is in part due to Go
and the Go community.
Go hits the sweet spot for
distributed system software."
High maintenance costs
ensure that your technology
can't properly adapt or
support business needs.
Go is unique among all languages
as it has been designed
to minimize maintenance costs.
Rapidly-evolving teams
are common at Google
and virtually all enterprises.
Go's simplicity, easy
readability, and single-binary
deployment ensures that
Go applications have
minimal maintenance
and that it's
relatively easy for
someone new to a code base
to safely maintain it.
Martin, a software
engineer at Trivago,
spoke of this hidden
benefit of Go.
"Go's simplicity and its
sophisticated tooling
let us scale not only our
service, but more importantly,
the process of software
engineering itself.
Reducing the friction of
onboarding and training someone
has a significant impact on
the company's productivity,
even more so at a
constantly moving
environment like Trivago."
And Benjamin Cane, Vice
President and Principal
Engineer at American Express,
shared, "After working on Go,
most of our
developers don't want
to go back to other languages."
Go and GCP will help you
sustain business growth.
Historically, CTOs have
needed to make an impossible
trade-off-- either choose to
delay launch as the team builds
a scalable application first, or
choose to ship a slow prototype
early, acknowledging that
development will be delayed
significantly later as adoption
growth demands a rewrite--
effectively having
to choose when
to be unable to support
business growth.
Go has eliminated this dilemma.
Go is designed for Google Scale
with built-in concurrency that
takes full advantage of today's
multicore machines and Cloud
Services.
Go enables programmers
to quickly develop
applications that perform
at scale, no rewrite needed.
Eric, a Software Engineering
Manager at MercadoLibre,
wrote, "With Go, the company
obviated 88% of their servers
and cut CPU on the
remaining ones in half,
producing a tremendous
cost savings."
Cloud computing brings
countless benefits
for flexibility and efficiency,
critical to sustaining
business growth.
Go is the only modern
language that has first class
support on all Cloud platforms.
Go is designed for
Cloud-native applications.
Over 3/4 of the projects
in the Cloud-Native
Computing Foundation
are written in Go.
And Go is designed for
container deployment,
with a very small
footprint, compared
to the "ship the world" legacy
languages like Java, Python,
and Note.
Mariano, a Software
Engineer at Movio,
blogged, "Our Go
microservices currently build
in 5 seconds or less, they test
in one or two seconds which
includes integration
tests, and they
can deploy (via
Kubernetes) new containers
in 10 seconds or less.
The key factor here
is small images."
Among all Cloud
benefits, serverless
has the largest potential for
sustaining business growth,
with its low cost,
instant scalability,
and expanded flexibility.
Go is an ideal fit
for serverless,
with broad support on
all serverless platforms.
Go has very low
resource use and nearly
instant startup times
compared to applications
written in legacy languages
that utilize interpreters.
Google's Cloud Run is the ideal
platform for Go applications
with seamless deployment.
Go and GCP help you
simplify the chaos.
"The biggest impediment to
a company's future success
is its past success,"
according to Dan Schulman,
the CEO of PayPal.
Today's business environment is
defined by modern enterprises
with a "move fast and
break things" culture.
Enterprises will need
to embrace the process
of constant transformation
to remain relevant.
Go provides the
flexibility and performance
to assist organizations with
application modernization
efforts, and GCP provides
flexible managed services
to guide your organization
into the modern era.
To learn more about Go,
its primary use case,
and to read case
studies of enterprises
who have transformed their
organizations, visit Go.dev.
Thanks for spending
time with me today.
I hope that you've
learned something.
I hope you enjoyed
it, and I hope
to see you at a future
conference or one
of the many Go conferences.
Thank you.